when people ask me where it all began
where my interest for mythology came
from the answer is always the same Jason
and the Argonauts more specifically the
1963 movie growing up in the UK in the
early 90s for whatever reason that movie
would be on almost every weekend without
fail and whenever I visited my
grandparents there was no cable TV so
having seen the movie about a hundred
times it's fair to say bits a story I
know quite well when I tell people this
the response I get most often is well
why haven't you made a video out jason
and the argonauts then and to that
question i've never really had an answer
that is until today because we are
finally looking at the story of jason
and the argonauts as they embark on
their epic quest to find the Golden
Fleece
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there are numerous tellings of jason's
quest for the golden fleece but the most
comprehensive comes from Apollinaris of
roads in his epic poem argonautica which
is one of the only surviving epics from
the Hellenistic period before we get
into the story it's probably best to
start with Jason's backstory and
heritage it's pretty much agreed upon
that Jason's father was a man named
Ehsan who also happened to be next in
line to be king of alko's a city in
Thessaly his mother however is something
that not every poet seems to agree on
Apollinaris and many others claim this
woman's name to be awesome edy another
pretty common belief is that Jason was a
descendant of the gods not quite a
demigod in the same vein as Heracles or
Perseus but there was some divine blood
there whether it was his grandparents
great-grandparents or even further down
the line some say it eventually stems
back to Hermes and others say it's
Poseidon but if it's just mere
speculation you may authorize us in
there for good measure
simply put Jason's father was a king his
mother was a beautiful woman and
somewhere along the line there is some
divine blood which is a fairly normal
backstory for any Greek Hera before
Jason was born his father
Ehsan was overthrown and imprisoned by
his half-brother and Jason's uncle Elias
who believed he was the rightful king of
southern Thessaly their mother pleaded
of peles not to kill a son and so he was
left alive but locked away from the rest
of the city
Ehsan eventually met her woman named al
Sammy D and she would later fall
pregnant with Jason knowing that peles
would have any child of a sons and hos
killed she did the only thing she could
to deceive the new king she had her hand
maidens weep and sew up when Jason was
born convincing peles that the boy did
not survive the birth she then sent the
baby away to keep him safe Jason was
raised outside of the city on Mount
Pelion by the Centaur Chiron it was best
known for educating God's demigods and
future kings if someone had the
potential to do great things from a
young age it's likely they would be sent
kyron at some point where they would be
taught a variety of skills from combat
and archery to medicine and philosophy
after he's rather eventful birth
Jason's childhood was fairly quiet and
uneventful it wasn't until he was a
young man that people would start to pay
attention to Jason the city of Caledon
had been played for years by an enormous
bore sent by Artemis when the king
refused the sacrifice in her name to
solve this problem the hunt for the
Caledonian bore became a massive
celebrated event attended by the most
prestigious hunters and even heroes such
as Theseus despite the sheer number that
joined in on this hunt the boar was
slain by Jason rather impressive for
someone who not many knew of especially
when you consider he was still in his
teenage years at the age of 20 Jason
finally decided it was time to return
home where King Pelias was hosting a
series of games in honor of Poseidon
after Jason was sent away as a child all
those years ago the king feared someone
would challenge him in the same way he
had done to his brother and so he
consulted an Oracle who told him to be
wary of a man wearing just one sandal on
his way home Jason came across an old
woman attempting to cross a river and
offered her his assistance in doing so
he lost one of his sandals downstream
the old woman then gave him a blessing
but this wasn't because he had helped
her this was because that old woman was
actually the goddess Hera in disguise
and she could see what the king had
planned for Jason and decided that he
needed all the blessings he could get
when Jason entered the city nobody knew
who he was but he was brought before the
king when they noticed he was wearing
only one sandal Jason knew that he was
the rightful king but pelas had planned
for this day he knew he would encounter
a man with one sandal he just didn't
know it would be his nephew the boy he
thought died all those years ago he
asked Jason a question
what would you do if an Oracle told you
one of your citizens was destined to
kill you
Jason laughed and told the King he would
send them to the far lands of Colchis to
retrieve the Golden Fleece for surely
they would fail and never be seen again
these words were spoken by Jason but
they came from Hera who believed they
would save Jason from an execution when
Jason then declared himself the rightful
heir to the throne
pellis did not deny his claim but merely
set the conditions of their deal he
swore to Zeus that Jason could take the
throne if he embarked on a quest to
retrieve the golden fleece a deal that
everyone would agree heavily favored the
king the odds of Jason returning alive
was slim and to return with the golden
fleece was considered impossible however
this didn't stop Jason except in the
offer but he wasn't foolish enough to
make the journey to Colchis by himself
first he would need a ship when he
managed to procure the legendary ship
known as Argo what many consider to be
the first ship to ever sail the seas now
he would need a crew to join him on this
voyage this crew consisted of a group of
men known as the Argonauts if you've
ever wondered where the name came from
it simply means Argo sailors or sailors
of Argo being named off that a ship they
sailed doesn't mean that they were a
bunch of random men that Jason picked up
off the streets to make up the numbers
the Argonauts were comprised of the sons
of Kings heroes and gods to say that it
was a raw the stacked crew doesn't
really tell the whole story some of the
more well-known names included Heracles
who needs no introduction pie Lea's the
father of Achilles the sons of the
northern wind known as the boriates who
could fly the divine twins castor and
pollicis sons of Zeus the legendary
musician Orpheus and the hearer of
Philoctetes who appears in numerous
stories including the 12 labors of
Heracles and the Trojan War
much of the crew was also made up of
hunters many of which took part in the
hunt for the Caledonian boar these
included you famous a son of Poseidon
who could walk on water the Prince of
Caledon himself
Meleager and the Huntress Atalanta who
was the only woman to embark on this
journey before they set sail they took a
vote to decide who should captain this
journey unsurprisingly they chose
Heracles but he rejected this notion
this was Jason's quest and he should
lead so with introductions out of the
way Jason and the Argonauts left
Thessaly and began their voyage to
Colchis the home of the Golden Fleece
modern-day Colchis is a stretch of land
that covers parts of Russia Georgia and
Turkey with the majority being in
Georgia the first stop of note was on
the island of Lemnos which is in
modern-day Turkey this island however
was far from normal it was inhabited by
a group of women who had killed all of
their husbands the women of Lemnos
ignored their worship of Aphrodite and
so she cursed all of them what this
curse did was make the women smell
really bad which sounds pretty tame but
were probably talking a stench that was
vomit-inducing
the men of Lemnos unable to bear just
being around these women spent most of
their time on mainland Thrace with women
who probably didn't smell like death
this drove their wives crazy and so one
night they just decided to kill all of
the men when they were sleeping the only
man left alive was king Louis he was
thrown into a barrel and left to float
away at sea by his daughter princess
sapele who in all this madness had
become queen sapele queen of the
disgusting smelling women a title you
could only dream of when the Argonauts
landed on the island the women decided
they would encourage them to stay Jason
has taken before the Queen and she falls
instantly in love the women then take
Jason and the rest of the crew home
leaving only Heracles and a few
stragglers to look after the ship so
either Aphrodite's curse had no effect
on the Argonauts and the women smelt
fine or they'd been at sea for that long
that they
care regardless it creates this weird
situation where Herakles is actually the
voice of reason which is ironic in
itself considering how many wives he
went through Jason and his men remained
with the women for longer than
originally planned every day the voyage
was postponed they would set sail the
next morning but the same excuse would
be used again and again
that is until Heracles decided it was
enough he rallied the Argonauts and told
them it was time to start behaving like
heroes retrieving the Golden Fleece was
their quest and they had made no
progress it does give us a small insight
into why the men may have chosen
Heracles to lead as without him Jason
would have fallen at the very first
hurdle
Jason fathered two twins with the Queen
and the rest of the Argonauts most
likely had a bunch of children they left
behind to continue this quest it does
raise the question as to whether these
children were born of the same curse as
their mothers it has no relevance to the
story but that is a pretty unlucky
childhood never knowing your fathers and
thinking it was no more torn of vomit
every time you went near a woman the
island of Lemnos just sucks anyway the
Argonauts losing their bearings landed
on an island inhabited by a group of
people known as the Dolan oi the
descendants of Poseidon they greeted
Jason and his men with hospitality
inviting them to join in on the
celebrations as they had just crowned a
new king king sized ekeus they also told
them to be wary of the Gianni's a race
of savage six armed giants who didn't
take kindly to trespassers on their land
as Jason and most of the Argonauts
celebrated and enjoyed the festivities
Heracles in a small group of men stayed
behind once again to look after the Argo
unknown to the Argonauts that you
jenny's watched as most of them went
into the forest and decided they would
raid the ship not knowing that a few men
had stayed behind
Heracles in the few men he had killed
most of the Giants buying enough time
for Jason and the rest of the crew to
return and drive them away so I guess
the reasons why Heracles should have led
counter is now at - Jason had been given
directions by king size ekeus so they
set sail that evening unfortunately they
once again lost their bearings and ended
up back where they started king-sized
accurse and his people seeing a ship
approaching in the dead of night assumed
the worst and with it being so dark
neither one could recognize the other
which resulted in the Argonauts
slaughtering the natives and the newly
crowned king-size ekeus was now the
newly deceased king
after a brief apology and the tending
King Cizek as his funeral piece was made
and when the weather improved the
Argonauts left the island for good this
time so to recap the story so far the
Argonauts have wasted a bunch of time
knocking up some cursed women killed
some six armed Giants got themselves
lost numerous times and killed the king
of the only people who have helped them
thus far stellar attempt at retrieving
the Golden Fleece at this point in the
story the relationship between Jason and
the Argonauts begins to fray when his
leadership is challenged when they
stopped off at the river seus to
resupply Heracles sent his squire Hylas
to fetch water but on his way he was
abducted by a water nymph Heracles an
another Argonaut named Polyphemus set
out to find the missing squire Jason and
the rest of the crew however sets sail
and when they finally realized that
there are three missing Argonauts they
turned to Jason accusing him of leavin
without Heracles on purpose out of
jealousy before this turned into a
full-blown mutiny the god Glaucus
appeared from the depths of the ocean to
tell the crew that it was in fact the
gods who are responsible for the missing
men this would ease the tension between
Jason and the rest of the crew as they
continued on they finally passed the
Aegean Sea and into the Sea of Marmara
where they encountered the Bereans a
group of tribes from Thrace that
migrated to Asia with many of them
stopping off in Turkey this time the
Argonauts were not given a friendly
welcome
instead King amicus challenged at any
one of the Argonauts to a fist fight to
the death
one of the twins we mentioned earlier
Polydeuces took exception to the king's
lack of hospitality he accepted the
Kings challenge and after a brief
fistfight he punched the king
to death when the guards tried to
intervene there was a standoff of the
rest of the Argonauts
after a while they decided enough damage
had been done and the natives fled which
means the murdered Kings counter is also
at - before leaving they stole some
cattle and took it back to the Argo now
this next part of the story is the most
memorable for me mostly because of the
movie the Argonauts landed on the
opposite coast of Thrace with a group of
natives they just encountered migrated
from here they come across an old man
named Phineas he doesn't question who
they are or why they're there because he
already knows the answer Phineas
possessed powers of prophecy so powerful
that not even the gods could hide their
dealings when he began to share their
divine secrets and reveal the future of
man that's when Zeus would intervene
Phineas was originally a young man until
Zeus cursed him with old age and
blindness which for Zeus to sound rather
tame but that's because there was more
whenever Phineas sat down to enjoy a
meal he would be tormented by a group of
harpies who would defile his food he was
blind old and always hungry despite this
he was pretty relaxed about the whole
situation because he knew jason and the
argonauts were destined to save him when
the harpies came that evening they were
chased off by the boria's so I guess the
ability to fly came in handy in return
for their assistance Phineas help them
plot a course to Colchis and he warned
them of the clashing rocks which happens
to be their very next obstacle the
clashing rocks saw the wandering rocks
are exactly what you would expect a pair
of cliffs that crash together whenever
something tries to go through them this
is where Phineas advice would save the
day he suggested that the Argonauts
allowed a dove to fly above the rocks as
when they crashed together it would only
lose its tail feathers when they then
reopened the Argonauts rode as fast as
they could
trying to catch these rocks off guard
and as phineas predicted this worked
the rocks reopened and slammed again as
quick as they could but the Argo
sustained only minor damage after this
encounter the rocks never moved again
so I guess being bested by the Argonauts
meant they just gave up squashing people
forever and just became regular boring
rocks finally reaching the Black Sea
they passed the river Acheron where they
meet King Lycus who hated the Britons
with a passion upon hearing that the
Argonauts had killed their king he gave
them more than a friendly welcome
luckily for like us this brief stop did
not end with the death of a king but we
do lose some more Argonauts sadly the
helmsman of the ship typhus died from
illness and the prophet Edmund was
killed by a wild boar they built some
graves for their fallen comrades and
moved swiftly on because at this rate of
travel there would be no one left by the
time they arrived in Colchis luckily for
the Argonauts they found some more crew
members when they came across three men
stranded by none other than Heracles
during his 12 labors when he journeyed
to the Amazons there was a fourth man
named the Sten Ellis who died during
this neighbor but the crew could still
see his ghost it was this ghost that led
them to his tomb where they found the
other three survivors and in order to
honor this ghost man who had just saved
them they all poured a drink in his name
they continued on once again this time
with their newly bolstered ranks until
they reached the river Therma Don where
they had planned to rest for a while but
when it was revealed that this harbour
belonged to the Amazons they quickly
left the next morning instead they found
a nearby deserted island with a temple
dedicated to Ares that they could rest
in the temple itself was only guarded by
birds which they easily fended off
inside the temple they found four more
stranded survivors these were the
children of frick seus and the
grandchildren of the king of Colchis
himself a tease as they were closing in
on Colchis they decided it would make
sense to have some natives on board and
so Jason welcomed them to the crew once
they were rested they set sail leaving
the island behind for the first time the
Argonauts had their destination in their
sights
but this was only the halfway point of
their journey
not wanting to announce their presence
just yet they chose to dock in the
backwaters so far the influence of the
gods on Jason's quest has been quite
small but this is where Hera and Athena
decided it was time to help Jason the
king of Colchis was quite a stubborn man
and so they decided that his daughter
may be the key to retrieve in the Golden
Fleece if they could enlist the help of
Aphrodite they could make her fall in
love with Jason when they visited
Aphrodite she was busy arguing with her
son eros she told them it was unlikely
he'd be willing to shoot his arrow at
Medea whilst he was in this mood Hera
then suggests that it was as simple as
bribing him to keep him happy and so
Aphrodite gave him a Golden Ball to
carry with him as he flew through the
sky which would leave a trail of gold
dust behind him resembling a shooting
star
this pleased heiress and whatever they
were arguing about before no longer
mattered back in Colchis Jason decided
that it would be best to first negotiate
rather than just storming in and just
taking the Golden Fleece they could use
the king's grandsons to help smooth over
this negotiation process when they
entered the palace Medea let out a cry
at the sight of her four nephews in this
commotion aris was able to sneak in
unbeknownst to anybody and fire his
arrow at Medea and just as planned she
fell instantly in love with Jason the
king was less than pleased when his
grandsons are asked for the Golden
Fleece to be taken back to jankis he
accused them of conspiring against him
to try and take his kingdom away from
him Jason tried to defuse the situation
and make a bargain with the king but he
just responded with a series of tasks
that he deemed impossible for Jason with
no other choice Jason reluctantly
accepts and heads back to the Argo to
inform his crew Medea is left torn
between helping Jason and facing the
wrath of her father or doing nothing and
watching her nephews and new love Dart
she tells her sister that she fears her
children may die if Jason is
unsuccessful her sister then convinces
Medea that she must help Jason
regardless of the consequences
Medea is extremely conflicted and it
starts to wear down in her mental state
to the point where she considers suicide
but ultimately she decided this would
help neither her nephews or Jason with
her mind made up however she arranges a
secret meeting between the two outside
of a temple of her karta Jason promises
Medea that if she helps him he will make
her the most famous sorceress across
Greece and she told him if he was to
forget about this act of kindness she
would fly to Greece on the wind and make
him pay Jason then tells Medea that
there is no need to fly to Greece
because she should come back with him as
his future wife to that question she
refused to give him an answer but she
gave him all the advice needed to
complete the trials ahead of him when
Jason returned to his men they were once
again divided some thought accepting
help from Medea was unheroic and the
others believed it was their best option
the trial itself consisted of plowing
fields that were plagued by
fire-breathing oxen entering the fields
with a blessing Medea and given him
Jason was able to wrestle the oxen
unaffected by the fire and began to plow
the field an army of warriors then
sprouted from the soil but Jason was
able to fend them off with the advice
Medea had given him knowing they were
coming Jason threw rocks into the crowd
as they sprouted unaware of where these
rocks came from the majority of these
warriors fought amongst each other
instead of stopping Jason Jason had
completed the trial and won over the
crowd that had gathered but king et's
returned to his palace furious and began
to plot a way that allowed him to cheat
Jason out of their deal the king was
aware of madea's treason but the Golden
Fleece was still guarded by a giant
serpent which he believed would buy him
enough time to stop Jason she warned the
Argonauts of her father's plan to not
honor their deal so they had to hurry
when they found the tree where the
Golden Fleece resided it was guarded by
an enormous dragon Medea had already
concocted a potion
would stop this beast and when Jason
sprayed the dragon it fell instantly
asleep allowing them to grab the Golden
Fleece and leave quickly and thus began
the long and perilous journey home to e
alkis sailing back the Argo was pursued
by several Culkin's leading the fleet
was madea's half-brother
absolutists who managed the corner the
Argo just off the coast of the bridge
Ian Islands here the local Kingdom
mediated peace talks between the two and
Jason was allowed to keep the fleece as
it was deemed to have been won fairly
Medea however was not so lucky she would
be tried for treason by the local Kings
a crime that she would surely be found
guilty of they instead came up with a
plan that would involve tricking her
brother into believing she would go
peacefully back to Colchis when he came
to collect her they would murder him and
chop his body into pieces the Argo set
sail and the remaining coconut began to
give chase but they stopped when up Sara
toises body parts were thrown overboard
the King would surely want his son
brought back in one piece to be given a
proper burial in some stories up Sara
tiss was dismembered to avoid the wrath
of the arenas and whether this worked or
not it didn't take into account to the
wrath of Zeus who would watch the entire
murder happen he summoned a gale that
blew the Argo further north
closer to Italy than Greece here they
came across the Enchantress Circe a
figure that Medea is often compared and
associated to she absolves them of any
guilt regarding AB sirrah toises murder
and they continued on their way this is
when we see her ago against Seuss's
wishes trying to help Jason get back
home she convinced the scene of Thetis
to give the Argo safe passage by telling
her that Medea was destined to marry her
newborn child Achilles in the afterlife
before meeting Thetis the argonauts came
across the same group of sirens
encountered by Odysseus
luckily Chiron had warned Jason before
leaving and that is why they needed
Orpheus a master musician when the
sirens began to sing their song Orpheus
took out his lyre and played a song that
overpowered their voices allowing the
crew to sail on by unaffected there was
of course a one organ or two felt the
need to jump overboard but he was
rescued by Aphrodite and taken back to
Sicily with the help of Thetis the
Argonauts plan the route they would take
Jason chose to avoid the Straits of
Messina and in turn Scylla and Charybdis
which was a wise choice considering what
happened to Odysseus they would instead
travel through the wandering rocks an
area where the sea was particularly
violent and treacherous with help from
Thetis and in a raids the Argo was
guided safely by their next stop would
be the island of Corfu where they
encountered the second half of the
culkin fleet which unknown to them had
continued giving chase the king of Corfu
Alcinous offered to mediate this dispute
once again he agreed that the Golden
Fleece belonged to Jason but Medea
should be surrendered to the Cole
consult the two get married in a sacred
cave leaving the Culkin's to go home
once again disappointed Zeus angered by
Hera's previous involvement sent another
gust of wind after the Argo knocking
them off course once again but this time
onto the shores of Libya isolated in a
foreign land like no other the Argonauts
began to lose hope there was no way home
this time until they were visited by the
three nymphs known as the guardians of
Libya who told them how to survive and
how to return to their home they would
have to carry the Argo across the desert
after 12 days they would arrive at Lake
Triton and the garden of the Hesperides
here the Hesperides tell them that the
garden was raided the day before by
Heracles
and he killed its guardian serpent at
Ladin encouraged by news that Heracles
was alive the
Argonaut set sail this time full of hope
that they would be reunited with their
friends and family as they journey down
the lake triton appeared to them and
revealed the route that would lead to
open sea now all but home there was one
last encounter on the island of Crete
with the bronze giant Talos who wouldn't
let them pass believing they were
pirates Talos was built by Hephaestus
and he had one vein that went from his
neck to his ankle Medea cast a spell
that would calm the Giant she would then
remove the bronze nail that held this
vein in place and talus would bleed to
death so after all this time Jason
returned home with the Golden Fleece and
celebrated with his people as the
soon-to-be king of a alkis he had
restored his family name he had a wife
and he had the Golden Fleece but one
thing still saddened him his father had
grown old over the years and was unable
to celebrate with his son Jason asked
Medea if she could take years off his
own life and give them to his father
she told him it was possible but Jason
wouldn't have to pay with his own life
she took blood from Ehsan and transfused
it with a mixture of magical herbs and
pumped it back into his veins which
restored his strength and youth King
Pelias his daughter witnessing this
demanded that she did the same for her
father Medea obliged telling the girl
that she could restore his youth and
vigor if they chopped him into pieces
and boiled them in a cauldron she
convinced Pelle as his daughter by
taking the oldest Ram in the flock and
boiling its pieces only for a much
younger ram to leap out of the cauldron
the girl needed to see no more and began
hacking away at her father in his sleep
and threw him into the cauldron Medea
however refused to add the magical herbs
and peles was finally dead many would
argue that peles had it coming for a
long time and either Jason or his father
should have killed him anyway madea's
actions driven out of spite and revenge
would backfire grossly
the king's son Acastus would rally the
people after his father's death Medea
would be charged with killing the king
and Jason would follow as an accessory
to murder
for those paying attention the King
slain counter is now at 3 they would
then travel to Corinth where they were
allowed to settle jason agreed to marry
the king's daughter hoping to gain some
political allies that would aid him and
take him back his city
but when Medea found out she was less
than pleased considering the vow he had
taken and all the help she had given him
Jason then revealed that it was
Aphrodite who made her fall in love with
him and if he should be thankful to
anyone it should be her she attended the
wedding and gave the bride a dress that
was cursed it stuck to her body and
burned her to death
taking the king with her when he tried
to help his daughter she then killed two
of the three children that she bought
jason fearing they would be killed in
retaliation because Medea logic I guess
she was able to flee Athens in a chariot
sent by her grandfather Helios before
Jason or the people of Corinth could
find her Jason would eventually reclaim
his throne when he defeated a castis
with help from Achilles father Peleus
his one remaining son with Medea
these'll as' would become the new king
Jason however lost his favor with Hera
and the rest of the gods when he broke
his vow to Medea and so he spent the
rest of his life alone and unhappy until
he died in the most ironic way possible
one day Jason fell asleep by the Argo
which at this point was old and rotting
and as I'm sure many of you have already
guessed it collapsed and fell on top of
Jason killing him instantly Jason's life
was many things but boring was certainly
not one of them he traveled the world
and went on an epic quest to restore his
family name he experienced things that
most could only imagine he married a
sorceress who was both brilliant and
insane and let's not forget that he was
responsible for the death of no less
than five kings
and a couple thousand people and some
Giants but we can just forget about them
it's an underdog story where Jason goes
from zero to hero and then back to zero
numerous times as crazy as the story is
it still feels somewhat relatable the
lines between who's good and who's bad
are always blurred and Jason himself is
far from what we would expect from a
hero he becomes the leader
only because Heracles turned down the
position he never really commands the
Argo every time he faces some kind of
test he has assistance and when disaster
strikes he isn't the first to step
forward or even come up with a solution
he isn't the ever stoic ever brave
fearless hero that is common in so many
of these stories
Jason is honestly a regular person who
at times is capable of great things like
we all are but even then he still has
his flaws which I guess is what makes
his story somewhat relatable in a weird
weird way for those who have been
waiting for these episodes to be
available as a podcast the wait is now
over starting with today's episode
you'll be able to download all future
videos and past videos using itunes
google play spotify and any other major
platform I'll leave a link in the
description for you to click on or you
can find it yourself by simply searching
the mythology in fiction explained
podcast on any major app or platform as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained reminding you to stay
away from Lemnos it sucks
[Music]